oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
so this consists of two parts the first
part is just my first sentence of
Michael : I've been working with him for
a long time and I just wanted oh the
next part I will use the whiteboard but
but maybe is better for the picture so
the second part of the talk about the
collaboration with Michael
Sebastian pull back a V and poof done so
for the last dis summer is kind of
really fortunate to work with Michael
especially its lucky to see how he do
research is basically like this first
part of the talk mainly speak to those
people who don't know Michael for those
people who know Michael is obvious so
for those who don't know about Michael
you know he still he was pitch
distilling for just finishes for year
and he just passed away two week ago
keeping his only two three years of PhD
he get a lot of first album with many
fundamental work in optimization for
example the first talk by Alexander
already talked about his work on matrix
scaling is the basic pressing and this
talk I will talk about our work on LP
request
and in this Tuesday album we will talk
about how to stop station with it how to
compute stationary distribution in Lille
linear time for any poetic WA and kill
it this is also a fundamental and he has
many many fundamental work just in three
years for example he got the first
polynomial term consisting of a minuchin
graph this problem have been studied by
many mathematician and convey scientists
for many decades and he first got the
parameter and for example he he am with
alex a few collaborator called faster
album for villa capacity me gospel also
if you go to the chrome he still have to
come back up for the putter cellphone
for surfing la pasión many many other
poems and in fact I suspect he will have
I don't know how many more people next
year will coming up because he worked
with a lot of people and in fact he had
a lot of secret to be self with other
researcher because where people asked
him question
he has a constant probability of solving
it instantly and when you happens then
here is a little secret with self that
collaborator so I don't know how many we
so he has more next year
and maybe I tell you about why is my
first research with him so my first wish
search with film is again about
requesting palm but this is the l2
requesting palm so the problem is very
simple I just leave one noticing I call
p.m. and set is the time to solve linear
regression with M constant and ripple
and set my lid on 0p i focus on album
with converging which lot one of epsilon
because it is not converging so i will
not talk about epsilon here but there is
some not term for in a while and
basically i we say is just this sentence
if you want to suffer M by M matrix you
just need to with the matrix a few times
and software M by M
matrix and we don't need to assume any
assumption on the matrix just within the
previous this has been extended to for
software many albums especially because
this album is very simple it just
involves sampling the matrix and then
use the sample matrix to figure which
constraint is important and then do
something again the funny thing I want
to talk about this researches originally
we have a kind of hacky proof but he
will ever settle with simple proof
usually whatever proof he got usually
used collect proof for this one if
you've got two sentence before this this
result just to give you a back one about
this poem before our research say is
even more complicated paper like fifty
page or something like this and at the
end he just got two sentence however I
will not talk about this you involve
some somewhere we care for definition to
get that to sentence so I always suspect
in fact he has a pocket but just we
cannot see it so except for being a
really good problem software he is also
where we could listener one special
thing about him is he left lead a white
pot to listen the proof even you have
very complicated proof with long formula
what he preferred to two years just
walking around the hall and then when
you tell him then if you suddenly
understand even for why we love proof I
remember this summer Santos is visiting
MS our and we have some type H proof of
something and then he's just walking one
and listen for the 10 M page and then he
keeps somewhere available
recommendation how to improve the proof
so it's really amazing and
the anything you see is really good on
funding mistake in a poof even though he
laughingly - with the poof you can still
find a mistake
I remember this summer I was suffering
upon man I was very excited because some
semi-important palm and I was trying to
explain him and usually he can
understand immediately but this time one
I'm a little bit frustrated because he
couldn't understand
I also toast a pass here about the proof
and he is also happy and few days later
we found a mistake because at that time
I'm doing my thesis defense yeah he
found quite a few missing in my paper
and they're suing time I don't know how
to fix the mistake and he can't fix it
so it's really amazing and certainly the
last really special ability of him is
chicken soft palm immediately this of my
again I tell him some math form which is
open for to that case after I told him
the next technology can be a poof
so it is kind of crazy yeah so if you
have students I don't know what paper to
read once the testing is to read his
paper
many of his paper is very akin and sort
so he is really good so today my talk is
a whiteboard talk so how to disable the
screen
so the problem we want to study is very
simple
the poem is just this I will go is to
minimize LP regressing where say a is M
PI D matrix states and crunching and T
purpose and our goal is to get a lot 1
over epsilon convergence tap elephant
and why we care about this poem so let
me give you some background for example
if you want to suffer hell one
requesting then what you can to use you
can surf it in screwed t iteration and
each theater isn't just evolving solving
some linear system and similarly for l2
there everyone know this is just a
linear system you can so you can surf
em1
for a limpet is again security and so a
natural question yes however P log in
those range before how I will result the
compass album is formally is the
previous best formula is square feet and
but if you the people's will show
yourself with an improvement on LP and
if you work on those album you public
and also both those we saw heat and you
could work a security but it's kind of a
natural for example you've pierced to
power then you should expect you catch
something closer to 1 instead of skill
still something square in this research
we have
this mystery is still not yet
and the key party system of with : now
we saw a showing we can do it in an too
serious
lecture we saw used to expect when P is
close to 2 that is something close to 0
and certainly one open question you can
ask is is can you improve that to T
because in practice meditate etcetera is
much more constrained my post so this
certainly is interesting when I will
only focus on this one may question why
this is difficult for example can you
just use the interim effort to get this
result and turns out we also put a lower
bound cannot get this formally what we
proof is photos who know YouTube for
method they work by you you have
correspond menu concert the self of
Cotton's Perry fencing for Tacoma set
and then used Luthor method to solve the
problem with the very in fencing and
what we proof is there is no Kusaka code
impaired fencing for ell people even for
l2 power 1 power so this is a result it
is the food P bigger than two only P is
one that is still on top yes absolutely
oh absolutely yeah
yeah so let me try to explain why this
problem is difficult
kill the keeping the correspond the most
natural way to software pop using X
liquid by using gradient descent so
let's see what is the palm of using
creatine to support this pole so let me
see say we for this talk at SES the
slack you can think s is always like ax
minus P our palm is to study a converse
formula look like this X to the P and
and the reason why you cannot solve soft
help increasing use incredibly changes
because this fencing is love really
well-behaved more particular 1s is seal
this fencing is lot
let me see is lot smoother for P less
than strictly less than two because the
first thing is multiply actually for for
peak with even to the end the promise is
lot Shawnee Commerce
so our idea is kind of really lecture we
just try to multiply the first thing
says that the first thing is in this
talk I will focus on this case because
in every sentence I need to switch
position to case differently so I'll
only talk about one case but the proof
is basically the same for example in
this case that what we want to do is to
make a fencing study most Johnny
Congress so turns out the way we do this
is see you
I put a function f the derivative of s
which we can calculate something look
like this and when you put the graph of
the derivative of the X to the peak the
part is something about this remember is
pillagin steelsuit
a 1 here the first thing is look like
that expecially imagine this is a
thousand year 26 legalize check like a
banshee oh and this create the you fall
within this N and what we do is
something like this we look at some
point P here we want to modify the
fencing such that this is jointly
Congress in the picture of derivative
then what we want to do is to make the
derivative look like lie when you said
sugar is a quadratic fencing so what we
do is just to find a strict like this
one and then we spay the origin fencing
by dispersing going from here to here
and a straight line and then going up
and in terms of formula the first thing
years something look like this so here I
call the first thing FP relativity fits
just this there is two case when s is
less than P then we want a straight line
as and otherwise is something like this
so our idea is try to solve the LP
requesting Bacchus play during the
fencing PI and the first thing FP that
is most on e-commerce a 1-0 certainly
you can integrate this passing and get
the origin form so you'll notice this
formula is chaotic because it's check
now here so the first thing yourself use
quadratic advanced zero and everywhere
else is just all which enforcing and
shift by a little bit one particular
lights feature about this person years
that for example F infinity is just is
just equal to the origin passing and
well I ask you it should be FC AB
serious the origin festering because
you'll ever modify what I'm sure yeah
FC is just the origin foot but yeah and
F infinity is quadratic so because we
won't modify the first thing so you can
let your future self or one fun thing
that you didn't get except solution so
what we two years we start with a
contract equation which we know how to
solve and then gradually decrease the
penalty while maintaining the shushing
of the poem so in some sense it is kind
of like Interpol method but instead of
coming up a period what we do is we
found a family function approximate the
origin fencing and gradually maintaining
the Sousa
yeah so there alpha mistis
so we stopped
when you start with a very large key
basically you start with a large enough
such that you can probably prove this
using of the FP is inside the quadratic
area type in your problems it's just the
quadratic form so you just solve by
using a linear system but yeah we are
suffering facepalm we start with some
very large P Wow linear system so then
they open is kind of like inter-party is
larger than some fascial the each
iteration the funfetti is what we do is
the launch step into point HL from each
step we will just do something like this
this step is pretty large is constant
and
and you step out from this very simple
we just used you use the excess liquid
in descent to fondle xxt with the
initial suturing last the last Xu cap
and this is basically the Alpha so in
terms o this stuff that I try to usually
when I give the talk people camping I'm
too fast this time I try to be slow
that's why I use a white pot hopefully
it's better so in terms of picture you
can find the say that the X infinity is
just contracting sousou-san of some
quadratic form you can solve and then in
some sense XT is like a pop and each
time you decreasing the P and then
gradually converging the zhuzhing and to
end isis al from what you need to poof
is basically every step the switching is
close enough and then you want to proof
when it's close enough then the palm
here locally just look like a
well-conditioned palm and that's why
extra liquidity sank and software we
efficiently so that is the pan yeah
large important you just square the one
income yeah yeah yeah you're very slow
important because what we proof is
exactly the same we give we so like this
with some lot instead you can use
excited as we are cheese some stochastic
gradient descent alpha what it gives is
even more interesting it will give a
running time I don't even remember but
it's roughly look like this
the thing I don't remember is the
exponent so we will be something related
to P the family is more complicated oh
and say is the number of lawn Julian in
a so this is linear thumpers some
polynomial unity and also one thing to
emphasize here especially is this is not
one of epsilon convergence so if you
have much more culturing than where post
and this is basically linear time what
this is interesting is because this is
the this is the second example of such a
search running time currently we only
know such running time for l2 requesting
and turns out this is also host for L
people crashing uh-oh
host this this exponent on P will also
pull up and P tends to 1 so it only host
pitch in P from 1 and infinity otherwise
you will solve LPN depo sparsity yeah
and certainly one really major problem
at least for me in you know for solving
linear programs is can you stop LP in
such running huh yeah in this talk I
will only focus on this part the second
thing is running time the first one is
number of iterations yeah
the first place of yeah so now we go to
the poof hopefully I can keep compete
yes oh so basically there is only one
there may in the proof creado whatever
people bye :
you'll be simple so this people is also
simple so the proof in what one one
concept is you see how you feel labor
food or pursuing so we call labor food
center as with greatest obvious this so
I will I will use the rotation for s and
X because s is always given by X minus B
so you can also think this sleeper for
justify for X so the labor forest is the
set of s prime such that s prime this is
coordinates P over 2 I still don't have
a real intuition of why is P over 2 but
this comes from the proof so this is the
labor and the Magnum is just this if you
for H less than something like 1 over 2
P after you do one step this one should
be t.a.s close to the origin point we
have the distance
this turn like this team in high or
polymer the dependence on pn1 was P P
must warn ya so this is the main level
of the proof so I will first show why
this lemmas advice so this proof is
basically showing every party's in Elgin
feel the power of the people spawn and
the radius in this metric is something
like this so yeah so let's see why
suffice so we met what we're trying to
meet my sister's fencing 1/2 L FPS I so
when you compute the Hessian of this is
something look like this basically this
formula is saying the Hessian is roughly
you move the Hessian of app and we've
some HX inside outside and what we want
to proof you is when you take a step
then the Hessian doesn't change too much
so
and yeah the formula of f double prime
is dude so so we need to compute F
double Prime
after Papa moistures because the first
part is you notice the after Papa me if
you differentiate this system is just
something like p2p much too and for this
part when you the pension is something
like a also SP over two so the so the
formula is what we like this just to
simplify the rotating you were some
people a lot move there but I will not
care about those all the proof I will
try to avoid writing those P theta
except in the exponent so basically
there is two case because we recognize
the first thing to make serious always
Johnny converse so the second derivative
is always larger than P to the P module
otherwise use like the Oh Jim festering
and so if we apply this formula what
happens is this the second derivative
years
first we little a papaya no advantage to
to estimate how fast the gradient
descent converge so for the upper panda
because s can only move by this amount
so we will upper bound by something like
this
the SP over two can move by this factor
and because the second derivative is the
exponent is P over 2 so you lead to
exponentiate this term by 1 minus 4p I
guess 2 and similarly you can know about
by something look like this
so the worst case for these fingers what
is the SS said that the ratio between a
Papa and our bun is the worse is the
case when s is exactly P because when
this term is lower than T then no bun is
always larger than the T better
so basically the okay maybe I call this
tummy's alpha this term is beta then
what we have is something like this
alpha alpha beta is upper part by up
upon the worst case is that the Omega T
is T to the P over 2 P plus 2 and the
numerator is something like s P over 2
plus and when this time equals to that
then the S is something like T P over 2
so this term is also like T P 2 and then
you have to scroll and he
and the T term will cancel away and this
term is just lovely and to a mass to
over P so the condition number for this
system if we can put this neighborhood
and the condition but it's an to one
mass to over P and if you use exactly
the descendant yes this Juanita so
basically if we choose to this lemma 1
minus HT that curve I think you have I
sub I that sounds like the ice core yeah
yeah sorry yeah yeah there I should have
all the subscript R everywhere I see
yeah oh yeah
basically all calculation yes
coordinates yeah
yeah so you only have one funny thing is
notice when you prove exactly the
descent one catches here imagine you've
to quit in descent if this reaching then
this estimate is already force so what
you lead to so you need to fix the
problem such that even though we only
put the up the region containing up and
curve upon half well conditioning we
want to make sure the whole problem is
well conditioning and what you can do
use for example imagine just imagine
here say we have just let's say we have
a one dimension conquest palm we want to
stop let's say you here the initial part
let's say you promise the obvious here
say we already know the palm is
well-conditioned here and but crazy
outside but what you can do is you you
find the quadratic faster state called
quadratically extend the function
outside the switching also you can
extend outside the switching and what
after doing this operation then the
whole problem is well conditioning and
basically you can do the same check here
and make sure the whole problem is well
conditioning and that's why the one
income is like this
oh but the costume will be the continues
the costume we will look like this form
and is pretty difficult to because this
is the what we exchanges on the ass
but the form is the Onyx yeah oh so what
we more precisely what we do each
iteration years we we will transform the
spacer set the initial upon the Hessian
is identity and wonder accelerate in
desert
otherwise you in the elf amused to
stopping some degree system somewhere
otherwise you need to make it assumption
on the matrix
yeah so in the last ten minute I will
prove this lemma this lemma this love we
requite too much interesting what you
little two years you just wait on the
OTE for the s and the estimate that that
OTE
we can do the calculation yeah okay but
I guess it's a good calculus exercise so
you in general to freak out the dynamic
for our automatic conditioning well you
can do a simple effect activity for on
the automatic on teasing so we call our
palm we soften this poem a transpose X
months P so we want to understand how
how the st change so what you do is
write on the KKT for this there will be
a chance for F prime T as I equals to 0
now you take derivative of this guy
you'll get a chance for F prime prime o
when you take as you always use t
remember paste to thing related to P so
and you take the VT place tutor for we
first activity for s then you get X
double prime a and T as des TPP and when
you take derivative of the F prime then
you get something like this and using
the fat s is X must be then you will get
something like this P X P P P or this is
0 you can move that term there
and you can you put that matrix there I
will start a glowing those pop those
things just follow tation convenient one
check for funding YouTube homophone is
try to make a terminal by purchasing
matrix and then ignore data and this is
not externally purchasing matrix so what
you do use a pie a on both side when you
apply a then you get better St then here
you get a time here
but this guy is still not a projection
matrix so all you to use you create
phantom term on both lap and white so
you create you have school F prime prime
there here you need to keep it back
and this is a projection operator now we
can start planting the outcome of this
guy because this is potassium matrix
alum of this comment by the last term
that is here this is where our formula
of F is important so we see formula of F
slowly important we have a formula here
we will compare say a pompom oti already
computer yeah I compute that P must - I
guess and and also you need to compute
derivatives of F Prime in terms of T
this one is just yeah
the talk will finish in few second I
can't you differentiate T here then you
will get P must we differentiate this
here P must free and this time a lot
depends on P so you see now you can
compute that up
I mean system so he from DT of square a
pompom here spanned by this divided by
that
so this will be this one
make sure this is cold
this is
Oh s is bounded by T because in the case
is 0 so this term is face 80 miles to
and yet divided by square P much - so is
P P much 2 over 2 so what it happens is
just up to up to this formula we're just
computing the formula of how exchange
and then the afterwards you just try to
fund this by how much f is changing and
now we're bonding how much F is changing
because we want to proof after one step
s does not change too much and so it is
in the neighborhood such that the palm
is the well conditioning and so the
accelerated design will converge fast
oh yeah so basically with that now we
are using our test sentence and you get
squirrel pom-pom
yes TT two long years because it is
coordinated pass by that term so for LT
lobbyists just add extra extra scroll
and fatter and basically that is done
there because of this L to long path we
know coordinate wise we use the worst
case impeded element this is part by out
to LA the so this will be remember you
need to divide by the Hessian so again
you have to case the first case the
Hessian is just T
myself English fun
oh and the funny thing is hessian
squirrel hep-c and just exactly
disturbed so for the first case is just
cool and and the second case is
something like this now we have the
panel on the derivative of s then you
just drink integrate along the pop and
you will get this is the proof
any questions LPS tron occurs when a
person cannot be both LPS uncovers I
hope this move there is a gap
yeah I I don't know I also don't feel
this proof is too generic to form use
for any other first thing I try to
generalize this proof I can offer any
fencing sense Feitosa so sir yeah but
the keep obvious you want to find a palm
such that the change of the tv-tv is
pacified to Hesiod he's insane this one
you look kind of similar to the Selkirk
others this one I am pretty sure and no
I believe logistic requesting is as
general as LP imagine give because the
logistic the question first thing is
something look like this and if you're
scary is really far away then the
logistic regression is just like value
and value is just like l1 and so I don't
think it's easy to get anything better
for logistic yeah then I don't know
there may be
any other question does this extent to
this like a general problem where you
have minimizing illness linear functions
subject to some equality linear equality
constraint and the Codex is in the home
oh you mean this I'll pee out just say
this is less than 1 something like this
basically you can always write ok so
first of all is the whole talk can
generalize if you add a linear
constraint on the LP linear cause into
the requesting and this appointment the
problem is you could first because you
can just use subsets move this term here
but you either give faithfully then
you'll be equality and then you can also
move that term in it then they were
pretty cool I'm trying to understand
pressure so for the self concordance
parameter whatever you are saying that
you have proved that for it is bounded
by n so what we put me is for LP call if
P is not - and if you're paraphrasing is
symmetric symmetric namely the favored
fencing is this then there's a head at
least n come some people and if you
don't have this we can prove n - 1 for
lower bond 20-year open problems
we have a break now and the next start
we start at 50
[Applause]